Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah,
I had my mic muted help okay
Sorry I had my mic muted hello hello how are you hi it's nice to see you again I missed
you I missed you too thank you for coming I looked angry because I was
confused because my mic wasn't on and I couldn't figure out why it's because I
had to mute it because I can mute it two ways I can mute it from the microphone
itself like this with my finger or I can mute it in OBS miss you more that's
not possible more like angry well I lose my temper quickly okay I lose my
temper quickly I'm okay I'm okay on this fine evening I'm a little bit tired
because I left my house today I know isn't that crazy isn't that crazy okay
um let me explain the premise here so
hmm
right let me explain the premise here so I have a folder with a bunch of
characters with a bunch of pictures of characters or people or like I think
even objects I'm not sure I didn't look in the folder obviously because it's a
game it's a guessing game right I know I touch grass isn't that crazy
but yeah it's a guessing game so um basically I'm gonna take my glasses off
I'm gonna move a little further from my desk so it's not as easy for me to see
and um you're gonna help me guess the character on screen um don't tell me who
it is please please please please don't tell me who it is okay it's a guessing
game for a reason you can give me hints but don't make it too off all obvious
what's my prescription um the my eyes are different but I think I think around
negative 5 yeah I had lip balm here but I think I lost it my lips are dry come
moisturize my lips for me please I feel like my voice sounds really correctly
today it's um probably from overuse how are we gonna give you hints if you can't
see I have I'll have chat open on my phone next to me I won't be able to see
chat on my computer screen but I'll have it open on my phone okay come here I'll
moisturize your lips yes please there we go come moisturize my lips for me I'm
ready should we play along if we're also impaired sure if you want to if you
want to now let me let me see if I can set it up without actually looking at
the folder of characters thank you for moisturizing my lips for me okay let me
see if I can pull it up okay this is gonna be hard this is actually gonna be
really hard okay hold on where am I oh there I am or should I do it no I'll do
it like this oh damn it my chat got frozen okay alright I forgot it had
background music okay okay okay okay
okay I'm gonna take my glasses off now and I'm gonna back away now so that way
I don't see any of the characters but I'm still gonna try to set up the the
screen capture without my glasses okay let's see if I could do this okay I'm
having a really hard time finding my finding my mouse right now okay I shouldn't
okay oh fuck which one's the screen capture hold on hold on um just like
capture and make that bigger okay okay okay let me um I have a feeling I
already know who this character is I have a feeling let me pull up chat real
quick oh shit I have to be careful fuck I saw okay hold on how am I gonna do this
I kind of saw it on my phone I'm sorry okay I'm gonna cover I really have to
be careful how do I cover my phone I'm gonna try to cover my phone with my
blanket so that way I can still see chat without seeing the screen so he'd win
you I'm all it's go Joe isn't it okay okay that one doesn't count let me go
away from my screen that one doesn't count okay next one okay um I see a lot
of green and I see I see like a lot of I see a lot of fleshiness I see a lot of
flesh color is this an object is this an object can you tell me is if this is an
object or not planet Namek I don't know what that is it's a person it's a human
no flesh person ball chin oh is it the guy from psyche with the ball with the
balls on his chin is that who it is is that who it is Peter Griffin yes yes yes
I forgot his name because don't remind me of his name I forgot his name it was
something stupid like what was his name it was something stupid Nendo Nendo it was
probably Nendo yeah thank you okay next character oh fuck this is too big I
can tell that this is Jenna Marbles here here here here actually I'm gonna go get um I'm
gonna go get a USB mouse like a Bluetooth mouse or actually okay I didn't set
this up right I was not ready I was not prepared my mouse can't reach me when I'm
away
No momentum
hold on ignore this stuff
Don't perceive me, I'm working here, what the hell, I'm getting tangled in this, okay.
Now I can reach a little further. I just have to, oh shit. Oh fuck, I can't see
anything. Is my tracking gone? Okay, oh shit. Where did the tracking go?
Hello? I can't even see chat right now because I'm so blind. Did my Vtube studio crash?
Huh? Okay, I'm gonna put on my glasses, hold on. Holy shit. Tracking is off. Yeah, I think my Vtube
studio is crashing because it's not working. Let me, at least I can move myself sometimes.
Oh, oh, no, there it is, it's crashed. Okay, let me try restarting Vtube Studio. Damn it,
we can't go single stream without scuff. IRL stream then? No, no, what do you mean IRL
stream? What are we doing? Hello? It couldn't handle Gojo's power, you're right. Okay,
there's my model. Now I just have to get it to work, get it to connect.
Damn it. I'm sorry for the scuff. Oh. It's not connecting.
No worries. Scuff is hot? No, it's not. I guess we can talk about something while I try. Who's
this character? It's me. We can talk about something while I try to fix it. Tell me a
cursed food combination that you like. I bet some of you guys eat some crazy shit. I won't be surprised.
Doritos and chocolate pudding? What the fuck? But why are you mixing sweet with savory?
Mustard banana cereal. Okay, now you're lying. Now you're just lying. Sweet and savory is good.
It's okay when it's just one thing, like that's also like one thing that's sweet and savory at the same time.
I feel dessert USB. I put hot sauce on bread. Are you poor? Why would you do that? Don't you
wouldn't you want to add something else?
Okay, let me try closing VTube Studio one more time.
Struggle meal? Well, what's your favorite cursed food? I don't have a favorite
cursed food because I don't eat. It worked. There we go.
And then I unmuted myself. I'm back. I'm back. I'm back. I'm back. Okay. I'm so sorry for the scuff of back.
I don't know. Gaming. Okay. All right. Let me take my glasses back off and we can continue.
Is this it? There we go. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Let me back up here.
Okay, that's obviously Jenna Marbles. The picture was too big.
Is that an orange? Is that an orange? It looks like an orange to me.
No? It looks like an orange wearing a bandana. Is that...
Is it a South Park character? It's not a fruit. Tiny dude. Big nose. What?
It's from Nintendo. Big nose from Nintendo?
Is it Mario? He has a whistle? Oh, is it the guy from Pikmin? Like, oh, oh. Yeah, it's Mario.
Space. The guy from Pikmin. What's his name? Oh, oh, something, right? Oh,
Cadet. Something. Olimar. Olimar. Olimar. Oh, thank you. Thank you. Thank you.
I don't think I'll get a single one right. Oh, that's obviously Kanato from Diabolic Lovers.
Right? Yeah, it is. We should play Diabolic Lovers one day.
Would you want to see me, like, get all flustered playing that dating song? It's one of my favorite.
Um, is that a napkin?
Is that a napkin? Or, like, um...
Mine close. It's a napkin.
Is it a ghost?
A dragon. A cute and funny dragon.
Oh, oh, it's, it's the dragon from... Oh, I don't know her name, but it's from that one anime, right?
Hmm. It's, it's the small... I know what you're talking about. I know what you're talking about.
It's the dragon girl from that one anime, right? Yeah, I see the blue eyes. I see that. I see that.
What anime? I don't remember the name. I've never watched this anime. Dragon girl something?
Dragon, dragon maid? I don't know.
Okay. Okay, okay, okay. Thank you. Do you know her name? Can you name her for me? Because I can't.
You should watch it. Ms. Kobayashi's dragon maid. Kana. It's Kana. Oh, okay, okay, okay, okay. Okay, thank you.
Oh, that's some... Is that a doll?
Is that a doll?
It's a bunny doll?
It's not a doll. It's a bunny. It's some sort of bunny. It looks like a starfish to me.
It looks like a starfish. Um...
If you see me closing my eyes, it's probably because of sweat squinting. Experiment gone wrong.
Traumatized rabbit.
Why is she so round?
Is it like... Traumatized rabbit. Is it Sheevee? I'm sorry, Sheevee. Into the depth. Sad bunny. It's the hair.
Oh, I see a helmet. It's the girl from...
The girl from Made in Abyss, right? The bunny girl from Made in Abyss, right?
It's not Big Junkers. Don't be weird. It does kind of look like Big Junkers.
Yes, Nanachi. Nanachi. Nanachi. That's what I was thinking of. I'm not good with names. I'm sorry.
That's f***ing... Is that Germany from Italia?
That's Germany from Italia, isn't it?
Yes, okay. Oh, f***.
Is that a ninja? It looks like she's in a ninja pose.
It's a toilet?
Lolli. Oh, she looked...
I'm not sure. Is it the girl from Toilet Bound Hanako-kun?
Toilet related. Dicorinacals. Okay, yeah, yeah. It's her, right?
I'm not farting. It's just my chair. I'd be honest if it was a fart.
Okay, okay, okay. I'm so smart. I'm so good at this game.
Why do I feel like that's Mercy? There's too much purple to not be Mercy. Isn't that Mercy?
It's either Mercy or like...
I don't know any other purple-haired characters. It's Mercy. I knew it. That's Mr. Krabs!
Is that a basketball player? Or like a football player? I feel like I see a football in the background.
It's you. Wrong sport.
Hey, brother, brother, brother. Oh, it's a Hulk Hogan, isn't it?
I saw... See, this looks like a bas... Not a basketball. This looks like a football to me.
What is that? And then it looks like he's pointing with his hand.
Oh, there he is. Okay, okay, okay.
Is this a wizard? Shadow Money Wizard King? It looks like a wizard.
Great hero. Great hero?
It looks like a wizard with a big beard. Is it not?
Old hero elf lover. Loves his dungeons? Is this a character from Dungeon Meshie?
He is the one true hero. I guess he's a wizard in the scene.
Autism elf? Is it the guy from...
You guys are being really specific with your hands. It's a...
Himmel the Hero? Is that it? Why does he look so much like a wizard? Oh, it is Himmel. Oh,
he does have a beard. Okay, it's Old Himmel. Oh, okay, okay, okay. I was wondering,
like, why does it look like a wizard with a beard? Right. This looks like a snake.
It's a snake, isn't it?
Am I should know this one? Is it not a snake?
Is it like one of those noodles that you have a string attached to and you can play around with?
Like, you pull on it like one of those fluffy noodles?
Star Trek VA? Mutant. It's a lot of things smashed together.
Is it a gummy worm? Is it like one of those colorful gummy worms?
No? Fluttershy's friend? You guys are being too obvious. Is it Discord then?
If it's Fluttershy's friend and it looks like a worm, it's probably Discord, right?
Yes? Yes. Fluttershy's boyfriend? Oh my god. Wait, do you guys ship Discord and Fluttershy too?
I think they're a really cute couple. I know he's like thousands of years old, but like...
He's so nice to her. Well, at the start, he's an asshole to her, but he's nice to her after.
I think everyone does, really? Okay, that's good. I don't know. I just...
Some people I think are weirded out by it, but like, I think it's cute.
All right, that's minty from my little pony. I could tell.
Is that a penis?
It's a psychic? Is it a psychic penis? Why is it shaped like that? It looks...
Is it Patrick?
She likes peanuts.
He's got a piercing? What do you mean he's got a piercing? Is it a penis with a piercing?
In the little girl, small. She has a famous mom.
Fucking...
Northwest? I don't know, Kardashian? Who the fuck is that?
A young child who likes peanuts. Her dog is big.
Her dog is big.
Tiny spy. Oh, spies and assassin. Oh, it's Anya. Oh, it's Anya. Is that a penis?
It's Anya. Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay. See, from my angle, it just looks like a
penis head. Like, I don't see anything else. Okay, that looks like a character from...
Demon Slayer? Let me get my water. Is that a character from Demon Slayer? It looks like a
character from Demon Slayer.
Useless. No.
Shonen character. Why are you guys calling her Useless? I feel like if it's a shonen character
in a ninja, then it must be Sakura if everyone's calling her Useless. Is that it?
Oh my god, you guys hate Sakura. You guys really hate her. Damn. It looks like a Demon
Slayer character to me. Oh, no, I see her now. Okay. Is that a monkey?
It looks like a monkey with blue hair.
Animatronic with blue hair? Is it an animatronic with blue hair?
Puppet. Five Nights at Freddy's Spider Mom.
What? This doesn't look like any Five Nights at Freddy's character.
It looks like, this looks like arms. And then this one too. And then, sorry, I'm using my thigh as
like a mouse pad. And then this looks like hair and then this looks like the face and these look
like little legs to me. Oh, like little, like feet. Freaky.
Helosis. She crawls on all fours.
Do I not, maybe I don't know sister location enough. Exotic butter.
Is it, is it the ballerina? Oh, it's the ballerina. Oh, okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. I see it.
That was really hard to see the details. Okay.
Is that shadow the hedgehog? That looks like shadow. Yeah. Yeah, I knew it. I knew it.
I'm so good at this game. Is that Sonic the hedgehog?
Is that Sonic? No.
I genuinely can't tell who that is.
It looks like, it looks like someone like on his knees, like looking downwards.
Bird looks like a thunder cat. Chicken feet. What? Chicken feet?
What bird looks like, what are you talking about? Adventure time?
Is that Ice King? Is this Ice King from Adventure Time? Oh, no, it's not. Oh,
it's like, it's like the original one. I forgot his name on. My voice is really bad today.
No, it's not the original Ice King. It's like, well, it is the original Ice King, but it's not the
the one we all know. It's like, it's like the one that Ice King got his crown for it from, I think.
Yeah. That's Kirby. Yeah, that's Kirby. Why does he have giant feet? What are these? Are those feet?
Those are feet, right?
Yep. Is that Goku?
Yeah, it's Goku. Oh my god, I'm too good at this. Okay, that image is too big. I can obviously tell
that's um, fucking, I forgot his name from regular show. The guy from regular show, the blue bird.
I know that one. Mordecai, Mordecai, Mordecai. Where's my mouse? I can't even see my mouse.
Oh, fuck. Congratulations. Oh, that's Grail from Black Butler. All right, this one I'm not sure.
It looks like a woman with short hair and a side shave. Is there fire in the background?
Not a woman. It looks like a woman.
There's fire? Is this a fire pender? Cave grade syndrome. He has a seal.
Huh?
I genuinely don't know. It looks like Gojo. Is this just another Gojo?
The fire is not important.
It's not Gojo?
White hair. I can tell that the hair is white. Is it another psyche character?
He's in the same classroom as Balchen. It's the psyche character that thinks he's getting
like hunted by the the dark something, right?
Shadow. Dark reunion. Dark reunion. Something like that. Yeah, that's him. I thought it was a woman.
Okay. Is this a shrimp?
Or a lizard with a hat? Or a snake?
Not a shrimp.
Not a cat? Cat by conference. Oh, you guys are being too obvious.
Is this is this person boots?
Chat's cheating. Yeah, maybe I shouldn't look at chat.
Yeah, it's person boots. Okay, hold on. I have to
I have to zoom in to see to see person boots. Oh, there he is. Okay. He looks like a lizard from far away.
Is this the guy from Dororo? Dororo? It is. God, I love that guy.
Is that a transformer? Is that a transformer?
I can't recognize transformers. I don't know the names of the transformers.
Or is it Darth Vader?
Or like a vampire or something? It's either a transformer, Darth Vader or a vampire.
Is it Megatron?
They're hot. Maybe I do see some boobies there.
Are they wearing a helmet?
Mommy, three misses. Skunk colored hair woman.
Um, is it a, no, I was going to say, is it a man? You guys said a woman already.
That's a whistle. The immovable doesn't look like bunch.
Oh, is it the girl from main and abyss? The one that's really hot and that tries to kill them
and looks really scary. She has like the funny hair.
To cover her bald spot. It is. I love this lady. I love this lady so fucking much. Oh my god,
I really want to drop fan art of her. She's so sex. Yes. Okay. Thank you. Megatron.
That's the girl from SAO. Yeah. I never watched that show. Is that Mr. Krabs again?
Or a car from cars?
Spider-Man?
Is that a car? It looks like a car.
Twitter. Billionaire Playboy, not Spider-Man.
Elon Musk? Is that?
I would not have been able to guess. I wouldn't even have been able to guess Tony Stark.
It's Elon Musk. Oh my god, it's an Iron Man suit. That's so funny.
This is some kind of monster.
Is it a bird? Some kind of bird monster?
Or does it have a beard?
I'm seeing like some sort of beard here, but then this looks like a bird beak on this side.
I'm sorry if I'm not even pointing at the right thing. I can't see where my mouse is actually
going. Spooky demon.
Basic offensive magic. Oh, is it the guy from FreeRen?
That, um, sorry if my model tracking is so bad. I'm really far away from my computer.
It's the guy from FreeRen, the demon that like, Zolt, Zolt, Zolt, Trac, Zolt, Zolt, Blab, Blab,
something, something. Zolt, Trac, yeah.
Yeah, it's that guy. Okay, okay, okay. Is it a bird?
All right, this looks like a Pokemon. Is this a Pokemon with like a tail?
Or does it have a face?
Is it like the Mewtwo evolution?
It has a face. It's an anime guy.
An anime guy with purple hair? There's not a lot of those.
Does he have human legs?
He do stand like Mewtwo, yeah.
And what's this thing in front of him? What's this big ass purple thing here?
Am I even pointing at it this thing? What's that?
Just like Prince Ali.
Is it the guy from, um,
um, I forgot the anime.
Something Maki? Maki? Is it the purple haired prince guy from Maki with the really big eyebrows?
Yes, the one with really big eyebrows, right? Is that one?
Oh, is this one he was a kid though? Oh, I think it's one he was a kid.
Okay, thank you. I used to read a lot of fan fiction of that guy. All right.
This is really hard to see.
All right, so it looks like an accordion or a book in the front and then like a hand holding it?
Is there even a human in this picture?
Like, it looks like there's like a book in the bottom left corner and then a bunch of skin color,
like, like, like someone reaching out, grabbing a book. Excuse me. Thank you.
There is a human. BL? Huh?
Huh? Is it a Genshin character?
Oh, it's, it's, um, is it CL? Is it CL? It is CL. Okay. Why does he look so fucking femboyified?
What happened here?
Wait, this is CL, right? Is this like AICL? I feel like something looks off here.
This is not my CL.
What the fuck? Is this one of those slimes from that slime show?
It looks like it's a slime with a hat on it or like a booger with a hat on it.
No.
Not anime. It's a meme.
Oh, it's the, it's the turtle from over the hedge. Someone said hedge.
It's the turtle from over the hedge. Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay.
All right.
All right. I see some skin colored stuff. Is this Gojo again?
Potatoes. He'll bite your fingers precious. Is it Gojo? Is it the rock?
It's us. Both guys obsessed with drinks.
Oh, precious. My precious. Um, Smegle? What the fuck is his name? Is his name Smegle?
It's Emmy Shut Up. Yes, his name is Smegle. Really? I don't actually, I never
watch this. I never watched this movie. I got it right. It's Gojo.
All right. This is a pink haired girl and she looks like she has big boobies too.
Right? Big boobies, maybe pigtails. Don't tell Strani.
Your colleague. People are saying tungsten rat. A rat. Well, if you say it's tungsten rat,
that's too obvious. If it's a pink haired girl with pigtails, it's got to be an iron mouse, right?
Yeah, there she is. She's not my colleague. I don't know her.
Is this Ciel again? An emo?
It looks like a really emo guy with a really long face.
No, very popular. Not Thursday. Future Emmy. True.
Tik Tok loves her. Snap, snap. What day of the week is it again? It's Saturday,
sorry, it's Sunday? Is it, is this character called Sunday?
Is it a man? It looks like a dude.
Wrong day. Day of the week. Oh, Monday, Tuesday, Wednesday, Thursday.
If I'm boy, twin tails.
She's got a pet hand. Oh, it's Wednesday. It's Wednesday from the Adam's room.
Oh, okay, it's not a dude. It's not a dude. Okay, okay, okay. Okay. All right, that's Mike Wazowski.
I can tell from the colors and the shape below that that's Mike Wazowski.
Is this nicocato avocado?
It looks like Nick. It looks like him.
All right, I can tell already who this is because the picture is humongous.
Are you, are you after fushi like I am? It's the, it's the antagonist from,
what's the anime again? To your eternity. I hate that bitch. She's so scary.
Okay, this is obviously the snowman from Frozen.
Okay, is this also a snowman? I see a really big white log in the middle.
Do I see a collar maybe?
Is it like a teardrop shape? Like a, like a white teardrop shaped head?
Snorlax's kid? Is it a Pokemon? Is it like the one of the Pokemon evolutions of Snorlax?
Blue cat. Blue cat. Um, blue cat. Tom from Tom and Jerry?
Nyan, nyan. He got pocket. It looks like a cat.
It's Doraemon. Oh, it's Doraemon. Oh, he's so cute. Okay, okay.
Now that's Tom from Tom and Jerry, right? That one's Tom, right?
No?
Wrong cartoon animal. So it is a cartoon animal.
Is it the bad guy from, from, um,
from, um, Sonic?
Like, Zeta Flare. It's Gojo. Is that Gojo Satoru?
What is Zeta Flare? Mickey's friend. Minnie Mouse? Goofy? Oh, it's Donald Duck. It's Donald Duck.
Yes! Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay.
Is that JoJo Siwa?
Am I being, am I being JoJo Siwa right now?
She ruined everything? That's a crazy small girl. Is it me?
Character from a really shitty game. Crazy girl from game. Oh, the Missouri.
Oh, it's, um, fuck, what's her name?
I know, from, from, um, the, the, the, from Arcane. The blue-haired girl with braids. Hatsune Miku.
Okay, yeah, yeah, yeah, I forgot her name. What's her name again?
What's her name? Jinx, jinx, jinx, jinx. Okay, okay, okay.
That's Johnny. That's gotta be Johnny. Yeah, that's Johnny.
Is this from Jujutsu Kaisen too?
What's his name? The guy with the finger. The demon. What's his name? I forgot his name.
Goja? Is it actually Goja?
All right, that's, um, from Harry Potter. The Bilbo Baggins. Fuck, that's not his name. But, um,
good, good, good, from Harry Potter, right?
What's his name? Your wizard. Hagrid, Hagrid, Hagrid, Hagrid. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Bilbo Baggins,
I'm sorry. I'm sorry. Hagrid, yeah, yeah.
Um, is that the guy from the live action of,
what's his name? The live action of, uh,
one piece, right? Uh, he had like a really stupid name, didn't he?
Luffy, yeah, Luffy. You know what's crazy? This guy looks like my dad when he was younger.
I was really shocked when I saw that. I was like, holy shit.
Is this a character from the office?
Is this Keanu, is this Keanu Reeves?
Your dad was king of the pirates? No. But he looks like my dad.
YouTuber. Is that the bite of it he said? Oh, it's Markiplier.
Ah, it's Markiplier. Okay, okay, okay, okay.
All right, now I don't see anything at all.
Um, it kind of looks like those Twitch streamers that have their butts out all the time, right?
That's what I'm kind of seeing. Like, like maybe the pool is over here
and then she's like standing right here and maybe Chad is over here. Is that it?
What? Hot as Disney character.
Hot as Disney character. Fuckin'
What's the hottest Disney character?
Um, Maleficent?
Furry, furry you, furry bait, furry bait.
This generation's Lola. This generation's Lola?
Oh, Officer Hops. Yeah, okay, okay, okay.
I got it. Right.
This kind of just looks like a bloody tampon. I'm not gonna lie.
Or like something splattered and died. Like fell against a wall and splattered.
Close. There's blood.
Biology? He's inside of a- he's inside you. Is it you?
Is this you?
The guy inside your blood right now.
What?
Protects you from bacteria. Oh.
Is it the red blood cell from that one anime with cells?
White guy. Yeah, he's a cell. No, unfortunately. It's the red blood cell, right?
Wrong color. White blood cell? Sorry. White blood cell.
From, um, I forgot what the anime is called, but yeah, it's about your body.
Yes, okay. Oops.
Oh my god, he's kind of hot. Okay. I like it. I like seeing guys covered in blood.
Okay. Is that Applejack? Oh, it is. Nice.
Is that the guy from Mulan? Mulan that goes did they send me daughters when I asked for sons?
Yes, okay. I'm surprised I got that. He looks really hard to see. That's an Enderman.
Yeah, that's an Enderman. I knew it.
Is that a diglet from Pokemon?
Or like a picture of a beach?
No.
Close. Skip it? Why?
Remember Anya? Is it not safe for work? Always a penis head, isn't it?
Okay, okay.
Oh, that's that's the guy from Dungenesshee. Uh, Lyos, right? Lyos. Oh yeah.
Is this another pony?
Like my little pony infected are you a pony? Is this a pony?
What? Oh, it's a Pokemon. You would fuck a Pokemon? Disgusting. Why would you do that?
Don't you insult my wife like that? Pokemon waifu? Wait, what? Third hot is Pokemon?
Oh, I forgot her name. Okay, okay. I see. Okay, fair. I guess I would fuck that Pokemon too.
I'm not gonna lie. She's pretty. She's really pretty.
I knew it. I knew it.
Okay, um, the color scheme is kind of familiar.
Kachun? My favorite slime. That doesn't look like a slime. It looks like, um,
strawberry shortcake?
Different sweater every day. Strawberry shortcake? It's just you?
Obnoxious little sister. Dipper's girlfriend. You guys ship Dipper in the, uh,
fuck what's her name? Mabel? Oh my god. Yeah, it's Mabel.
She has a pit pig. You do?
Nasty. Oh, this is the thick girl from, uh, Dengen Reshi.
Yeah. We're pinballs. Of course we do. They hate each other, though. They don't hate each other.
They love each other. Pacifica tin? Tin. Pacifica tin. You ship Dipper in Pacifica?
Okay, that's cringe. I would, I would rather you ship Dipper in Mabel than Dipper in Pacifica.
What the fuck? Okay, that's the guy from the office. That's, um, Michael from the office, isn't it?
I ship me with you. That works too. No, not Michael.
Did someone say Dwight? Don't tell me who it is. Is it actually Dwight?
Michael wishes he was though. It's not Dwight.
Oh, it is Dwight? Oh, don't tell me the name. Oh, it is Dwight. Okay, okay, okay.
Is that Jack Black? Is that Jack Black?
Yeah, Gabe Bowser? I knew it.
Is that Freddy Fazbear?
It's either Freddy Fazbear or, like,
it's Freddy Fazbear. Okay, okay, okay, okay. We're doing so good. Oh my god.
Oh, shit.
Okay, give me a hint. Is this a man or a woman? Because right now, all I'm seeing is blobs.
You don't know who it is?
Is this a heavy anime? It's a man.
You don't know. You don't know. How am I supposed to know?
Oh, it's from, um, it's, um, from, uh, fuck, what's the anime?
Right? From, um, um, um, um, the one where the girl, high school host club, or on high school
host club, right? Yeah, yeah, yeah, it's one of the twins. I can't tell which one it is,
but I think it's one of the twins, right? Is that a Tilt-O? Is that a Tilt-O?
It looks like this part goes inside of you and this part comes outside.
Indy video game character? Is that Barney?
I know Barney is not really Indy, but is it Barney?
Does he have a bone? You're gonna have a bad time? What?
Nagito's boyfriend? Huh?
What? Tumblr loves this guy.
The one-slip? I literally don't know.
Megalovania. Oh, is that Sans Undertale?
Is it Sans?
Yes? Nox Taco? It is? What the fuck? Oh, it is! I was wondering, like, why is he purple?
Okay, okay, okay, okay. That's Icy. Is this also Pokemon? I feel like there's two characters here, right?
Okay.
Wind, Pokemon. Very old. He's bald.
Bald. He's older than he looks. Just one character.
Is it Naruto? I know Naruto is not bald. Oh, it's Saitama! Is it Saitama?
Air.
No, but he's bald. Is it the last Airbender guy? I don't know his name.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. The last, I don't know his name. What's his name? Aang, Aang. Or is it Aang?
Ah, okay, there we go.
That's talky room shake. I can recognize the memes, like, immediately.
She doesn't know Aang? I told you guys, I've never watched that show.
All right, that's a spider. That's like a dead spider. That's a crushed spider.
Or, like, an octopus. Or, like, a fluffy octopus.
Ah.
Mommy, mommy, mommy. Why are you calling for mommy? There's no mommy here. What?
Is this demon hair, hair witch, Dante? Who's Dante? Best game waifu.
Hair witch. Is it the witch, hair witch? Is it the mage from Freerun that can control her hair? She's not really mommy, though.
Rich gay aunt, four guns.
Is this Bayonetta? Is it Bayonetta?
Yes! Why does she look like a crushed spider?
Oh, okay, okay, okay, okay. Now I understand why you said mommy.
Oh, that's Yumi from Legal Witches. Oh, that was too close. It's the Pikmin.
Is this the big boobied girl from One Piece? I don't know her name.
Yes, yes, Nami, Nami, Nami, okay.
God damn it. Every time the picture loads, it, like, enlarges it, so I know that this is the bad guy from, um, Wreck-It Ralph.
Right? Is that him? That's the bad guy from Wreck-It Ralph, right?
Mm-mm, okay. Let me close my eyes this time.
All right, there we go. That's...
Is that a woman? Is it a woman? Or is it something that's, like, an object? Gross.
Is this a real, is this an alive thing? Is this thing alive?
Who is this? It's a woman. It's a woman. Is she wearing a black skirt? Or black dress?
Some people see this as an object. Shut up. I think you got the wrong folder.
You can never tell. What?
Yes, a woman. Okay, you guys don't know this person, huh?
Is it Lady Gaga?
Or is this JoJo Silla?
A zero IRL? Bro, what?
You got me really confused. Fleshwear.
My browser history.
She works in a store kind of like Walmart. Oh, oh, it's the, it's the hot, it's the hot,
it's the hot one from Superstore and she's wearing the sexy, the sexy, um, police outfit.
Isn't she? Yes, I love this character. She's just like female Dwight, basically.
Ah, okay, okay. Okay, how come you guys don't know her? She's so fun. You guys should watch
Superstore. It's really good. It's not JoJo Silla.
Okay. Is this the under-dragon from Minecraft?
Yes. Okay, nice. I kind of recognized it. Fuck, that's Chewbacca. Okay,
I gotta close my eyes. I forgot I need to close my eyes. Okay.
This is, is this a bald man?
Immune. Zombie. Zombie? Is it a, it's a bald man, right?
No makeup. Flesh version of a character.
It's a bald man, right? Long hair, female? Name a woman.
Me. Naughty dog.
Not bald. It's a girl. What the fuck? A girl that caused a lot of uproar.
Dude, it literally just looks like a bald man with a beard for me, wearing like a green sweater.
Oh my god, should I zoom in more?
It still looks like a bald man with a beard.
Oh, okay, okay. Her hair was blending in with the background. It's Ellie from The Last of Us.
Okay, okay. Her hair was blending in with the background. Okay, like,
like this darkness here looked like a beard. Wait, is it Ellie? Yeah, it is. Okay, so these
pictures are like so low quality. How do your eyes work? They don't work.
Is this Kirito from Sword Art Online?
Yes, okay. Damn it, that's Azura.
Is that Saw? Like Saw from the show, the show, the movies? Jigsaw?
Adventure Time.
There's no Adventure Time characters that look like this.
Daddy? He's a king? Huh? Adventure Time characters that you would call daddy.
I wouldn't call any Adventure Time characters daddy. They all look stupid. Maybe Ice King.
I've got to go take care of things. Oh, okay, goodbye. Thank you for spending time with me.
Vampire Knight. Oh, literally a daddy. Oh, it's, is it, is it Marceline's dad from,
from Adventure Time? Marceline's dad? Of course I would call Ice King dad. Have you seen Ice King?
Wait, it's not Marceline's dad? Huh? What?
Marceline Orangine? Is it like the original, is it the guy that like,
the one that they killed, right? In like Adventure Time, Stakes or something. It was
called Stakes or something, right? Where's his suit? Yeah, he's like the, the vampire,
I don't know, king or something. Yes, okay. Oh, yeah, I remember. Yep, yep, yep. Wait,
really? Is this him? He looks so ugly. Okay, next.
Is that the guy from Killing Stocking? I don't remember his name. It's a Korean name,
Yoonbum? Something like that? Yes, is his name Yoonbum? Did I say the right name?
Sinji? Wait, his name is Sinji? Yes.
Which one is it? Is it Sinji or Yoonbum?
I thought it was Levi. He does look like Levi, doesn't he? I read a good chunk of that webtoon,
I did. I have been closing my eyes when I've been, when I've been going to the next one because it,
it makes the image big enough for me to see. Levi Fanart. Okay, next. That's Sheeby. It's too easy.
That's the fucking sexy, uh, that's the sexy lion from Ice Age, isn't it? Diego.
It's either Diego or a piece of like, or some Cheetos, a pile of Cheetos. It's kind of like one
of the, it's Diego. You, you don't like Diego?
Why sexy? You don't know the appeal behind Diego? Some of you guys got to, you know,
think more like a furry.
Think more like a furry.
Diego is free. Yeah, he's got a good voice. He's got a good voice.
Diego has a girl? I know, I know, I know he does. Don't worry, don't worry. I would never leave you
for Diego. Is that like green onion? Like a leek? Or a paintbrush?
Bitch, I know, that's what I'm saying. He's a doctor. Animate Bill Nye. Oh, Dr. Stone.
I don't know his name, but it's the guy from Dr. Stone, right?
Noble Orient. Yes. Ah, it's not a leek. I like how it says E equals MC square there.
Okay, next. This is a bald man. This is a bald man. If I've ever seen a bald man in my life,
this is a bald man, right? You can't tell me that this is not a bald man.
Thank you. All right, now the rest of it. He's wearing a suit, right? Like a body suit,
like a skin tight, like, you know, it's like red in the front, maybe. Oh, is this the Deadpool?
Is this Deadpool? Spider-Man? Yes, I'm so good at this game. I love Deadpool. That's one of my
favorite characters. That was Hatsune Miku. I wouldn't have guessed it even if it was far away.
Um, okay. Is this a lizard? Is this a lizard or a dragon, maybe?
Daddy Jack Black? It's Bowser. It's Bowser. Obviously, you can't say Jack Black and expect
me not to say Bowser. This is Mickey Mouse, right? Yeah, yeah, it's Mickey Mouse. Okay.
Um, is this a hand? Is this, is this a hand?
A hand? Or a finger? A hand or a finger?
What do you mean DMCA? What's DMCA-ing?
Have I shown something? Am I playing something due to DMCA?
He sweeps.
Not a head. No, a head. No, a head. Oh, it's a head.
Is this Goku? Is this one Goku? Or, um,
um, maybe, um, Al from Death Note? I can tell that it's got black hair, maybe.
Disney Ninjas. Definitely Kocho.
He wishes he was Goku. What does that mean?
Dude, I don't know.
Lego Ninjago? I've never watched Lego Ninjago. Is this a, is this a Lego character?
A cry baby. He's so, he's so sad. Zoom in a little.
Oh, it's the guy from Devil Man Cry Baby. Is that it?
I'm so smart. He'd be crying. Thank you. That one was hard. That one was hard.
Is this a British man with a, with a gun?
Good girl, so smart. Thank you. Daddy. Daddy? Is this, um,
is this also from The Last of Us? Pablo? Oh, fuck. I forgot the actor's name.
It's something Spanish sounding. It's not Pablo though. Um, best that ever.
Yeah, you got it just with that. Pedro. Pedro Pascal. Is it Pedro Pascal?
Is. I'm Pablo. I'm so sorry to any Pedro Pascal fans.
Is this like, um, Pablo Escobar?
Did he just get British because of the mustache? I'm gonna be honest. I didn't even see a mustache.
It looked like a British soldier. All right. Is this a pool picture? It looks like a pool picture.
Is this Deku? Is this Deku again?
Someone in a swimming suit or something?
No.
Is this from my children's? Is this, is that Ash Ketchum? From Pokemon?
A boy you think? Is it Ash?
No.
What is this? Is this, um, Astro Boy? Is it Astro Boy? It's a girl?
Oh, is it the girl from Dororo? Dororo?
Is it, it looks like the girl from Dororo. Yes. Yeah. Okay, it's, it's not Astro Boy.
I mean, that was close.
Dude, what the fuck? Is this a piece of paper?
And a pen?
A map? Is this, is this the map from Dora?
He's Quebecois? Married a whale? What?
Is this a human being right now?
Why is everyone saying Cheeto, Canadian? They did the worm.
French, is this Justin Bieber?
Is this a streamer?
Played Overwatch? Welcome to the jungle? What? Streamer? Is this Ninja?
Is this Ninja?
What the fuck? Streamer. She doesn't know.
Stranny competitor when it comes to yapping. I don't know.
Twitch streamer, top chess player. Oh, is this a...
The guy that's really muscular and bald, right?
Six monitors? Oh, it's XQC. It's XQC, right? It's XQC.
It's not XQC? Yes, yes it is. Okay, okay. Oh god, that's a jumpscare.
I couldn't tell that it was XQC at all.
Okay, that's Garfield. Yeah.
Is this Tiger's from Kung Fu Panda?
Piece of paper. Hates Mondays. Yeah, I got that one.
It's Tiger's from Kung Fu Panda? Yes? Okay, wow. I'm still good at this. Let's go.
It's Kochun. Oh shit, that's Shrek. That's so obviously Shrek.
Is this PewDiePie? Or the Joker?
Or...
Is this like the Great Pyramids with the face on it?
Arcane again. Father figure.
Huh? Arcane father figure?
Did nothing wrong die to good dad? Ah, shit.
Um, is it the one that adopted Jinx? That one?
Yeah, yeah, okay. I don't know his name, but I know who you're talking about.
Yeah, that guy. Okay. PewDiePie?
PewDiePie? This is fucking egg.
That's the egg from Shrek, right? Is this from Shrek? Or something else? Puss in Boots maybe?
Puss in Boots, yeah. Mercy's Nemesis? Humpty Dumpty. Wait, why is Humpty Dumpty Mercy's Nemesis?
Um, is that death from Puss in Boots?
Whistles. Mercy hates eggs? Wait, really? Let's go.
Mercy, why does she hate eggs? That's Bill Sliver! Let's go! Bro, I love that character.
Is that it? Did we reach the end? Hey, I got like half of them right without your help, I feel like.
Oh, Mercy's allergic to eggs. Oh, the man himself. Okay, let me get my glasses back on. Hold on.
Let me look closer.
Hello. Oh my god, I can see clearly again.
Good job. Thanks. I really did good, didn't I? Say I did.
Here.
Oh wait, why did I do that? I'm being stupid, I'm sorry. I turned off my ring light for some reason.
There, I need that light. Good girl. Thank you. Thank you. Here, we've only been streaming for,
god damn it, my thumb is getting stuck.
You're not blind? Guys, I'm so blind. The only reason I was able to guess some characters
is because, like, they're color palettes. I saw the color palettes, but if, like, stuff like XQC,
where he had like, um, things around him, like, when it's really muddled with other color palettes,
color palettes around them, it's like way harder. But yeah, thank you for all the praises.
So, hold on, let me go back here.
And, oh, chat has to catch up. And what the frick?
Gay? Why are you acting so gay? Test.
Oh, thank you for the $25 Anonymous. Anonymous rat. I forgot to change my, um,
I have once again forgotten to change my alerts to the, um, to my headphones instead of my speakers.
10 out of 10, thank you. Holy shit, chat is taking forever to catch up. Well,
since we've only been streaming for an hour, 35 minutes, I think for the last 30 minutes,
we're going to continue the confidence. I like the game, not, I like the game too much, not to
continue. Just for 30 minutes, just for 30 minutes. Okay. I like it too much. I literally,
I'm so, this game's got me. Okay. Just for 30, just, just a little bit, just a little,
just a little bit. I'm glad you like it. I'm glad I like it too. Okay.
Because I don't want to end too, too soon, you know? Great. Let me sit back. How do I do this again?
Oh, fuck, no!
No, what the fuck? Okay, sorry. I went back, I went to the ending screen by accident.
Um, okay. I know she is literally me. Okay. I promise it's just for 30 minutes.
I promise it's just for 30 minutes. Continue this one. Okay. Right, what were we trying to do?
Yeah, I have no choice, basically. Like, I have to play it. You know, like, like, I have to. Like,
I can't, I can't not. You're here with me right now, you know? Apparently approved by the devil
if the graffiti on the wall is anything to go by. You're here with me right now. We're here together.
It's basically like I have to. Oh, background music is so on. Thank you for telling me.
That's annoying. There we go.
Uh, go back to Ashley. Okay, okay. Thank you for telling me that too.
Thank you for holding my hand through this. Oh, shit! Okay.
Ashley! I'm back.
Are you done snooping on the cultist? Yeah, so there's apparently a little cultist club
where they all gather around for some demons and treats, but they can't summon for shit. Absolutely
nothing showed up. Nothing showed up on this end either. I don't understand. It was a vision for sure.
Chapter one? Aren't we on chapter two? I thought we were on chapter two.
Can you pull chat down a bit? Oh, no. Oh, here. Here's what I can do.
I'll make it smaller for you. There we go. So now you can actually read what they say.
There you go. Yeah, we're on chapter two. Thank you for telling me that too.
Okay, um, I don't understand. It was a vision for sure. There was like...
You hear a car?
That's him. That's the guy who slid our throats in my dream. So the first guy wasn't him.
Yikes. He really just went in our room like that. You still doubted me? Where'd he get the key?
Should we just leave? We're supposed to vacate the room in the morning anyway.
Our stuff was still in there. What stuff we sold off most of the junkie we're hoarding?
I am not a hoarder. It's important stuff to me. Ten out of ten. Thank you.
And I can live without the trash and laundry. Well, like someone pointed out, we can't keep
wasting money buying new clothes. I am not risking my life getting in there to rescue our socks.
Well, I am. I like my socks. What's this game about? It's about me and my life story.
I like my socks. I put a lot of effort into finding cute socks.
It's my better bra. Actually, this new one sucks. I don't wear bras.
Still not interested. In fact, I'm somehow even less inclined now.
Scuff. You know nothing of my troubles.
Regardless, I think we have to kill that guy though.
This is no random burglary. He's specifically, he's specifically after us for whatever reason.
Yeah, it's a game about us.
No bra, just band-aids. It's actually tape. It's black tape. It's not, it's not band-aids.
I don't wear bras either. I am also a man. I am, I am also a man.
I'm kidding. Um, this is no random burglary. He's specifically after us for whatever reason.
Like somehow he tracked us down. So even if we run away now, we won't, won't he keep coming after us?
That's not wrong, but why is he still in the room? We're not even in there. Well, if I was him,
I'd figure, I'd figure we're getting, we're, ah, I'd figure, I'd figure, I'd figure we're out getting
food or something. So now he's probably waiting to kill us upon entry.
Unlikely, since he wants to go about this quietly.
I say one wrong thing and you guys are all up on me.
He's definitely hiding in that closet or something, waiting for us to go back to sleep.
Then he'll kill us in our sleep, just like in my vision, again. And you know this how?
I know because that's what I do. Duh. Plus he's using a knife. So there.
Listen, Andrew, just trust me. I thought about these things. You question, you question not why
she's thought about such things. Now, enough dilly dallying. Let's get in there and pretend we forgot
something. Minor, minor smelling air. Oh my God. That was not even on purpose. Okay, context.
I posted an audio on Twitter and instead of the word though, I typed out thought.
I meant to type out though, but instead I typed out thought and I
I quote, tweeted it saying like, I'm going to kill myself. I made a minor spelling error
in my horny post, but instead of spelling error, I wrote smelling error.
Thoughts and prayers.
Then we'll lure him somewhere less conspicuous. And then what? You have to ask? Sigh.
Let's go kill that guy.
Actually, he's still armed. They can take this guy. Yeah, she has a gun.
The hitman is nowhere to be seen. He's got to be in there, right? I didn't see him leave. Go in.
Leave this to me. This has got to be the stupidest thing we've done so far. No, let's go kill him.
Personally, I think shooting fireworks indoors was dumb, but hey, opinions,
which if I may add was also your idea. No, it wasn't. I was 12. You should have stopped me.
So should I talk you out of this one or no, shut up. Follow my lead. She's just like me.
I know, right? He's being such a little pussy. Let's just kill him.
You are Ashley. Yes, I am. That's fucking right. Go in the closet.
Oh gosh, Jolly Andrew. I just realized our impromptu night walk to the store has left me barged.
Is that so? Let us return to the gas stop at once. And since we want to be also quick about it,
let's take a shortcut through the park where we may frolic amongst the foliage shielded from sight.
I love the hitman music. Is this hitman music?
It's kind of loud for me. How's that sound? Huh? Terrific. Let's go.
Not so fast. Let me grab my things first. I just realized that I don't trust the staff here.
Given that you're about to roam around with a hitman around, would you like to save the game?
Should I save or should I not save?
Stop talking British. What do you mean? Do you want me to talk British?
Should I go British mode for the last bit? Save? All right. I'm going to save.
I'm going to write this save. Be a good girl and save. I'm always a good girl. All right, let's do it.
Well, congratulations. You have found the hitman and died, which is the best part.
There's more of the record. Andrew doesn't fare much better. When it comes to cutting people up,
I'm losing the accent. When it comes to cutting people up, the hitman whoops his amateur ass dead.
Though, given his romantic streak, he probably didn't want to live without you anyway.
Good. Good. He shouldn't. I mean, he shouldn't.
I bet you'd be happy about that if you weren't too fucking dead to feel anything.
The hitman wins and, ah yes, the world is much better off without you. However,
this is also anticlimactic. You get a free do over. All right, good thing I saved.
Yes, it is Emmy. It is Emmy. I know I'm really good at doing a British accent.
It's really hard to tell. It's really hard to tell that I'm not British.
You know, Shibi mentioned this earlier. But the other girls have told us that we sound the same.
And I thought of a good idea for like an April Fool's joke. Maybe Shibi should become me for
one day. And I should become Shibi, else you run Shibi's channel and you won't even be able to tell
the difference because we sound so similar, right? Right? Say yes. You like British Emmy?
Oh, good. Can we go? I didn't pick up my things yet. Come on, hurry up.
Okay, actually, where the fuck am I supposed to go? What am I supposed to do? Oh.
Got washed laundry. I'm trying to not talk in the accent anymore.
Indubitably. You'd be able to tell the difference? I don't know. I think if I practice, I might be
able to get it good. Pretty good. I just need to practice. Okay, genuinely, what am I supposed to
do? Can we go now? Holding the door open for me, are we? What a gentleman. Just letting in some
fresh air in the sounds of the city. Hurry up and get your things. I did. Okay, now what are we supposed
to do? Are we done? I would figure it out. I could always spot my cutie motel. I'm not sure.
I've never actually been told I sound like anyone ever.
Which is a good thing, I guess, because that means I sound, you know,
you know, original, I guess. Other than Shibi, I guess.
Head to the park? Is this the park?
Oh. Here we are. Is he coming after us or not? I don't know. I thought he would.
Let's pick a corner we can ambush him from. What corner? It's all bushes.
Um, I don't know behind a bush.
An abandoned shopping cart. Very classy.
You sound like Imi. I know. One of a kind. There's only one me. Oh my god, that reminds me.
I probably shouldn't bring up drama, but I want to talk about it. Did you guys see the Twitter,
the VTuber on Twitter, that like, here, the street will hide us nicely, allegedly, allegedly,
copied, like, Shiley Lee's design and also her voice.
I love drama too much not to talk about it.
What are we going to do if he just stays at the motel? Well, I guess we'll just leave then.
We'll grow eyes in the back of our heads and keep watching over our shoulders at all times.
Yeah, you saw it. You saw it. It wasn't that so crazy. I saw the VTuber before, like,
they kept getting in drama, like, little dramas here and there about,
about, like, copying Shiley Lee's design, but then I think when the voice clip came out, it was like,
way, way worse. It got bigger.
A YouTube video on that didn't watch it though.
I wonder how anyone even remotely familiar with the VTubing scene has not seen it.
I don't know. It depends how chronically online you are, especially on Twitter.
What a pain. I can't believe I'm actually hoping he'd show up now.
Good. Don't feel bad about murdering a murder. And on that note, not it.
You're making me do it again?
Yes. Dude only has a knife. You got this.
I hear footsteps.
Ashley, wait. I've never fired a gun.
Crap. I think he stopped. I can't hear anything anymore.
You can't ambush a killer that's waiting to ambush you.
And you can't very well start looking for him.
I'll let you use Twitter for art.
Well, maybe it still showed up on your, on your page.
Ashley, it's such a rat.
I've erased every girl from my mind except Emmy.
Perfect. That's exactly what I want.
Yeah. Why are you, why are you even saying that you saw this drama?
Huh? Are you looking at other girls on Twitter?
Why are you even admitting to me?
Okay. I'm kidding. I'm kidding.
I like drama too much not to talk about it with you.
I use Twitter for art too.
Art.
Crap. Did we whisper too loudly?
Is he onto us?
Why do you stop to see what we're up to?
Bet this all looks suspicious as hell.
This doesn't look like anything.
He shouldn't even be able to see us from behind this.
You dirty boy. No, we can't do it here.
Tee hee. Off I go. Come and find me.
I don't want to.
Ashley, seriously. I don't, I don't know how this thing works.
No peeking. What is she, what is she doing?
Does your alt count as other girls?
No. Cause my alt is me.
I only checked Twitter to see me.
So I don't actually, oh my God.
Really? You actually, thank you.
You actually checked Twitter for me?
That's nice of you.
Um, uh-oh.
Oh, I'm back to being Andrew.
God damn it.
He doesn't know how to use a revolver.
What a noob.
Time has come to play hide and seek with the killer and Ashley.
Um, Ashley.
Not much else.
Nothing. Didn't she go this direction?
This way? Nothing.
Here?
An attempt or several have been made to please trash where it belongs.
They were so, they were all so close but couldn't quite stick the landing.
Ashley, you're scaring me.
Nothing.
There's nothing but trash in this bush.
People think they are so clever hiding their candy wrappers in beer cans.
What do you mean this isn't going to end well? Save?
Okay.
It looks like someone has gone through the bushes here.
Ashley.
Ah! No!
Uh, shoot!
I did it! I didn't even need to, I didn't even need to reload the game.
Uh-oh.
If you find him fire once, wait, I fired multiple times.
Ashley reclaimed her gun.
Oh, fuck! I fired multiple times. Is that bad?
Is it going to come back to haunt me?
Uh-oh. No more gun out of ammo.
Oh, shit.
I get, and I walked in and I started blasting him.
I panicked.
This thing is useless now.
No one knows it's empty.
I guess so.
Do they still bullets to just anyone?
Do you need a license?
Should I reload?
Can I not get sex ending without reloading?
What do I do?
Reload the save.
Okay, I'll reload.
I have no idea.
Sorry, Ashley.
Although I wouldn't have wasted them at all if you hadn't made me shoot him.
Are we still playing the finger pointing game?
I thought we'd agree to leave that behind.
Let's just get out of here before someone sees us.
Oh yeah, and what the fuck was that?
What was what?
You running off out of the blue.
What? You need an excuse to start rummaging through the bushes.
Now that the hitman thought you were looking for me,
he sat there waiting to kill you.
That's your concern?
Of course it's my fucking concern.
No reload needed for that part.
So should I reload or should I not reload?
He didn't know you had a gun and would kill him.
Instead, I'm a bloody genius.
And what if he was in the bush you ran off to, huh?
Genius?
Well, he wasn't.
Quit your bitching.
It all worked out.
Clue me in the next time you have these genius ideas.
Yeah, that's literally why we started the game.
I'm getting that fucking ending.
Reload so you can do it again.
Okay, I'll reload.
All right, he was over here.
I'm only going to shoot him once.
Shoot.
I did it.
Nice work.
I have a few choice words to say to you,
but this is neither time nor the place.
Say them to me.
Degrade me for it.
Let's get going before someone comes to see what's up.
Those extra five bullets might come in handy.
Okay, thank you.
Yeah, first try, first try.
Got it first try.
Okay, quit your bitching.
It all worked out.
Okay.
Good girl, not unloading on someone else.
I would only unload it all on you.
Okay, let me see that.
Okay.
Okay, now where do I go?
Back to the hotel?
That's what I want to hear.
Oh, can we look in this car?
It's locked.
You know, it would have been pretty smart of me to steal his car keys before coming here.
You sure it sure would have.
I'm dumb as a stone.
What's your excuse?
I am at the mercy of thy whim, Starling sister.
Well, you should read my mind then, God damn.
My bad must be lack of sleep.
I'm sure he's still right where we left him.
All right.
Yeah, let's steal his car.
I didn't think about that.
Give me all two inches.
Shut your horn mouth.
It's bigger than two inches.
As long as no one saw us do it, who's going to have a clue it was us?
How this guy carries knives with him?
He's clearly a criminal.
Maybe the authorities will assume his friends got to him or something.
Do you prefer shoot or shoot?
Well, I prefer the right ending shoot.
Don't check the tree.
Ever the optimus.
Hmm.
Whatever.
Let's just go before someone comes to walk their dog or something.
He called me baby.
Ah, yeah, baby.
Leave those fingerprints all over the guy.
That's just great.
I'm sure you meant to say something else.
I guess it doesn't matter since you've never gotten your fingerprints taken.
Have you?
Yeah.
Motherfucker.
What for?
My driver's license.
Well, good thing it's me.
Manhandling.
Oh, my God.
I don't have my driver's license either.
That's so funny.
Okay.
Let's go get the car.
Is this driving simulator?
Am I going to have to know what?
Are we supposed to meditate mindlessly?
Sits on top of his car seat.
Amy doesn't drive?
No, I don't drive.
I don't know how to drive.
Driver's license are just a suggestion.
Exactly.
You don't have to drive.
Public transport is fine.
If you live in a city with good public transport, that is.
Newspaper cutouts of various incidents.
Most of them are about your old apartment,
both the tainted water and the fire situation.
There's also an article from last week
about some chemical leak in some other city.
I'll drive you around.
Thank you.
I'll be your passenger, princess.
You can drive without a license
as long as you don't get caught.
I'm going to get fucking caught.
Um, is that all we needed?
I can't go in the front seat, can I?
Oh, I can.
Oh, my God.
Look at him sitting on my lap.
All right, let's, let's see.
Oh, see if this guy has anything interesting in his car.
So much for not leaving fingerprints.
It's a little late to worry about that.
You've already touched the door, the handle, the wheel.
It's fine if it's me, right?
I fell in love with various papers
inside the most notable one reads,
Dear Mr. Washing Machine,
consider this a receipt for your cleaning service.
We're extremely grateful that you accepted
to clean our laundry for us.
Am I tall enough to drive?
I can use a booster seat.
Isn't Waymo like expending into more cities,
self-driving cars or no future thing anymore?
That sounds dangerous.
I don't think I should be in a self-driving car.
We're so confident in your services
that we will not be needing any progress reports.
In fact, please do not contact us
if anyone were to ask,
the less we know, the better.
As a bonus, we've included free samples
of all the new soda flavors
from our sister company, Happy Washing.
Are we the laundry?
Seems that way.
Yikes.
All right, let's get this motherfucker on the road.
Right, right.
I like driving.
It's common.
Driving is so freaking anxiety-inducing.
I hate driving.
Um.
Use my laugh instead.
That's dangerous, too.
I'm not breaking the law.
We should go.
Where to?
Could you elaborate?
We're off to somewhere, right?
Got the car and everything.
This isn't exactly the best situation
to go joy-riding in a stolen car.
We barely even have enough money to feed us.
Fine.
Let's go take-
Let's go take moms.
For fuck's sake, does everything I say
go in one ear and out the other?
Yes.
We're never going to talk to anyone
we know ever again, remember?
Did I say squad about talking to her?
Let's go rob the bitch, blind, and leave.
Amy, you're blushing, by the way.
I know I'm blushing because I'm playing this game.
Self-driving cars don't get tired, drunk, sleepy, or emotional?
Emotional?
Oh, I guess so.
What money do you think she has exactly?
I'm sure she's got something.
I thought she inherited some jewelry from grandma.
Oh yeah, but she can't sell those.
She can't, but I sure can!
Oh no, we still can't go over there.
I do love you.
Shut up.
I do feel bad for the father?
Why?
Andy is you.
Don't worry, Andy is you and I am Lele.
We've got pursuers or something.
Our parents' place is definitely something they've looked into.
Listen, Andy, wrong.
Andrew, the pursuer is taking a nap in the park right now.
Do you honestly think you're anywhere near important enough for someone to hire too?
If anything, it seems they assume that guy took care of us and that's that.
But the thing is I'd rather be overly cautious than dead.
Best we let her find out, what do you mean?
Wait, did I get something wrong?
Does the mom- was that spoilers?
We'll be quick.
Don't spoil her chat.
Wait, is that what you mean by she likes Andy?
Were you talking about someone else?
Okay, okay, okay.
So now you want to kill our parents?
Great.
You just said we can't talk to them anyways, so they might as well be dead.
Holy shit.
I'm way too tired for this.
Fine, we'll just rob them then.
Break in while they're at work, get some money and then get lost.
I'll take it.
Where do they live now anyways?
I know the place but I don't remember the exact address.
She actually told you the address?
Yeah.
Huh, the only thing she told me was to stop calling her.
She probably figured I'd tell you then.
I was talking about you like Andy.
Well, I like both of you.
Do forgive me, Ashley.
It didn't seem like relevant information at the time.
Whatever, just drive.
Wait, he's driving?
Will we be fine?
Just don't distract me with anything.
Okey-dokey.
Feet on the floor.
My god, it's not even your car.
Shut up and put your seatbelt on.
This sucks.
Yeah, it sucks.
No hurry up.
It'll be, it'll be goddamned if we get caught in that dead man's car.
Just because we got pulled over for some stupid shit.
He's a foot finishes?
Is he actually?
Was he gonna get distracted by her feet?
Huh, is that why he took them off?
I do like it when a girl puts her feet on the dash.
That's why I do it.
Make me then.
Do you or do you not want to go rob her parents?
I said, I said make me, Andy.
Okay, what do you want?
If it's to piss me off, then you're nailing it right now.
Oh come on, it's just a joke.
Ah!
I know it's not a joke.
Yeah, it is.
You get so mad.
It's just funny.
Like, I don't know you, Ashley.
You pulled this shit before.
I have no idea what you're talking about.
You'll keep going, Andy, Andy, until I get tired of correcting you.
Yes, I will!
And suddenly it's Andy and Lele and stupid bullshit all over again.
Way to read into it.
I was honestly just joking around.
Well then it's not funny and you're going to stop.
Nothing is funny to you anymore.
Well, are you going to drive or what?
Ashley is hot?
I know she is.
I just don't want us to get in trouble.
But you don't have to be such a hard ass about it.
I do, though, when you're such a dumbass about it.
You're a dumbass, too!
Just drive.
Are you angry?
I'm looking out for us.
Yes, I am!
Fucking drive, Andy!
Drive, Andrew.
And so he does, finally.
And you decide to give Andrew the silent treatment until you apologize.
I do that, too.
I do.
I love the angst, too.
I love it when they argue.
That's my favorite thing ever.
I do give people the silent treatment when I'm mad at them.
You're not sure what he needs to apologize for exactly,
but you won't forgive him until he does.
Because he was a little bitch to me.
And coming hot moment?
Yeah, gaslight and girlboss.
So while you wait for him to notice,
you're not talking to him, you fall asleep.
Uh-oh.
Another dream.
Amy, you're such a w-
What the fuck is that supposed to mean?
Huh?
What is that supposed to mean?
Call me a woman again, bitch.
I'll show you how big my dick is!
But at the same time, you feel wide awake.
Where am I?
Hmm?
Stop!
Oh, I'm sorry.
I'm sorry.
Oh, Arce.
Your soul.
Huh?
What?
Who's there?
Where are you?
Where am I?
Is this another vision or what?
There's no response.
Oh, this note.
I kinda wanna do it now.
Shut up!
Huh?
Where am I supposed to go?
I'm lost.
Oh, can I go in the top right?
I mean top left.
Upper right.
Pick the red flowers.
Can I not pick them?
I can't pick them.
On the bottom.
There's no...
I can't.
Ahem.
Red flowers make the path.
Pick red flowers to make path.
Is there other flowers that I'm not seeing?
Interact with the top right path.
And then I have to pick them.
Right?
There we go.
Ah, I'm so smart.
Okay.
There we go.
I hate mezes.
There's nothing to step on.
Okay, I can tell!
I know I'm blind, but I have my glasses on now.
Tarsal summoned you.
Can't tune in.
You're all muffled.
I can't hear anything.
The voice continues talking,
but you can't make heads or tails of it.
You scatter petals to keep going.
Okay, okay, okay.
I keep fucking blinking like a frog.
Why do I blink like that?
I promise I'm not blinking like that in real life.
I have to fart, but I'm not gonna do it.
Actually, no, I'll mute my mic to do it.
Okay, I did it.
Wait, I have to do it again.
No, it's not coming out.
Whatever, I should focus on getting out of here.
Oh shit, it's connected.
Are there other flowers?
My mute?
Because you've been a bad boy today,
so you don't deserve to hear any...
Oh, fuck, it's connected.
Fuck!
Where am I?
Everything looks the same.
Take these flowers and then make a path to go here.
Was I?
It's been 30 minutes.
Let me get to the hot scene.
Isn't the hot scene coming?
What are these?
Uh-oh.
Hello.
I see why I summoned you before, right?
I know, I mean.
I like to tease you a little bit.
No, I still love you.
You think I don't love you anymore?
Because I won't let you hear me fart.
Where am I?
In a dream, I called you here.
Well, can you wake me up then?
I was in the middle of something.
Doesn't even occur to you
that you should be afraid of this soul-stealing creature.
You got a long way into the hot scene?
What? I thought someone said hot scene incoming.
Hmm?
The hot part comes after you meet your parents.
Oh, man.
Um.
I'm- I'm literally-
I'm really debating on continuing.
No, I'm not going to do it.
I can't, I can't.
I don't want- I don't want to burn out.
I really- I- I can't.
Okay, wait.
Let me get out of this cut scene.
What if Andrew tries to talk to me?
He needs to know I'm deliberately ignoring him
instead of being in a coma or something.
The demon couldn't care less about
the lover's pet you're having with your brother.
It carries on as if you hadn't said a thing.
You used my gift.
What?
Was it useful?
Seeing the future?
Yes, the ticket- the trinket you gave me.
Um, yes, it's been very useful.
Thank you.
Then, do you want to see the future again?
Sure, I just have to keep holding on to it, right?
It is out of energy.
I'm able to recharge it.
Do you want to make a deal?
Of course you do.
Very nice scene incoming still- oh.
You're confusing me!
Never has it ever been a bad deal
to make deals with devils.
A bad idea.
Let's hear it then, what do you want?
Human souls.
Well, you're not getting mine,
so if that's- if that was it,
then not yours, tar soul.
Is that like an insult or something?
Who's then?
Just anybody's?
And why do you- why do you go-
why don't you go get some souls yourself?
I cannot enter the human realm unsummoned.
Like, you cannot enter here.
I am able to reach you only because of my talisman.
But even then, one can only interact
between realms through deals.
Do we have a deal?
I don't really get it,
but I can't say I'm all that interested either.
It's been just over 30 minutes, too.
I know.
There's a lot of good scenes,
but the one you want is a couple hours away.
The sex!
Listen, I really need to go back to my brother.
If I offer you a soul,
you'll make my talisman trinket dream thing work again, right?
Correct.
Sounds good.
I do have a soul or two in mind, actually,
but I'll see what Andrew has to say about it.
He's kinda- I don't know.
Something is shifting.
I don't really like it.
I probably wasn't the right entity to talk about this.
I will be waiting.
Right, all right.
I'll see what I can do.
So how do I wake up?
You wake up once your mind returns home.
Huh?
Farewell, Tarsoul.
Sags?
Gags?
Gay gags?
Okay, which direction should I go?
Up or- or upper left?
Say gags?
Gags?
Oh, I guess I can go both directions.
Left.
Okay.
I just want to get out of this demon place.
Um...
Oh, there's flowers in the top left.
I want to see Andrew before we end.
Okay, I'll try to get you to Andrew.
Here you go.
Okay, I'm guessing we're not supposed to go through that door.
Right.
Why was that a 4 out of 10?
That was good.
That was nice and loud and clear.
Which door?
The left one, right?
Yes, 9 out of 10, 9 out of 10, 9 out of 10.
Let's do right.
You don't know?
Save and follow your heart.
Am I going through the right one?
No, why not?
God, I have to pee.
I'm going to hold it in.
I'm going to hold it in just for you.
Um, whatever this is, it looks unfinished.
Okay.
Oh, shit.
Let it out just for us.
I can't do it on my chair here.
Isn't that a fetish?
Pissing on you?
Um, I'm guessing they all have to look towards that thing, right?
Did I finish it?
Hold it as long as possible.
You're trying to, you're doing something to me here.
Okay.
Now it's complete.
Parcel.
Yes.
Well, hello again.
This is not the path to your home.
Oh, up here is my realm.
You must return to your own.
I thought I was already in the demon world.
This is the realm in between.
Entering the wrong well.
Well.
Trust the process.
Okay, I'll listen to you.
So it's fine as long as you are summoned.
Why not just summon me to your realm?
Why summon me here in this crap land instead?
Return home, Tarzel.
I'm expecting those souls.
You can't tell me there's another realm and not show it to me.
Return now.
Uh, leave me alone.
Where am I now?
This is so tiresome.
And I've had it up to here with these stupid flowers.
Die.
Yeah, fuck these flowers.
Fuck your flowers.
Fuck you and your flowers.
I'm going to break them all.
Yep, yep, yep, yep.
I'm going to stomp on them all.
Let me out of here.
Ah!
You'll hold it until we give you finish.
Yes, I know.
And he's not you.
Help, get me out of this shit hole.
Come on, wake me up.
It's not funny.
I'm trying, jackass.
Do something.
Help me.
Oh, thank god.
I was a hair away from taking you to the hospital.
Huh?
Why?
That would screw us over, wouldn't it?
You wouldn't wake up no matter what I did.
God, Ashley, don't scare me like that.
Ah, stop calling me a good girl.
I'm trying to focus on the cave.
My whole freaking body is like really freaking...
Stop, stop, stop, stop.
I can't, I can't.
Okay, mom and dad should be both...
Both...
Mom and dad should both be at work right now.
Whenever you're ready, I guess.
You're only being nice now because you treated me like shit last night.
I treated you the way you deserved to be treated.
No, you didn't!
Yeah, scratch that.
Considering you kept pushing me around all day,
I think I was pretty fucking lenient.
Piss.
I'm not feeling anything.
This episode is titled
Andrew and Ashley and the Home Sweet Home Invasion.
What kind of knockoff cash grab show is that?
I'm not interested.
Now you know how you make us feel?
I guess so.
Well, it's definitely all about cash grabbing.
Haha.
I mean, boo, no thank you.
No, I saw that you're into it.
Let's go.
No, it sucks.
But I'm so nice that I'll roll with it now.
Free parking, that's why.
What?
Let's finish the game.
Okay, okay, we're done.
We're done here.
Quit.
I can't.
Fucking hell.
Um, um, um, um, um, um, um.
Who's streaming right now?
Um, um, um, um.
Here let's go with the Zura.
Do you guys want to go say hi to the Zura?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Uh, yeah.
Just ask for permission.
I don't want to.
do I have to are you really gonna make me do this yes I can't believe I'm
doing this can I please have permission to go pee after I end stream please you
may go don't say no say yes please please you can okay okay fuck you for
ask oh my god okay I'm gonna go pee now bye I love you brother